60 minutes correspondent Leslie stalls
award-winning career spans more than 40
years she served as CBS News White House
correspondent and moderator Face the
Nation covering some of the biggest
stories at home and abroad but she says
her most important job is grandmother 26
year old jordan and three-year-old Chloe
she writes about this role in her new
york times bestselling book bestselling
author that has a nice ring to it let's
install becoming grandma the joys and
science of the new grandparenting it's
about to come out in paper book but
leslie joins us once again at the table
to discuss or should we say good morning
lolly you should say good morning lolly
what are they going on that's what they
call me yeah and I decided that I had to
come up with something that would be
easy for them to say so they would call
me what I wanted them to come so I'm
lolly and my husband is pop and we are
what we pop oh that's nice but it's been
a year since you've been on the road and
since you've released a book are you
finding more and more people love
talking about this subject don't they my
goodness if I go to a book signing or
give a talk on it people raise their
hand and want to tell their stories most
of them are wonderful and happy some you
know yeah some are not but generally
people are so thrilled to tell you about
their grandchildren especially if like
me my your children make you wait yeah
forever and ever but you also say that
this gave you Ben grandpa gave you a
chance to atone wow how you were if it's
it's two things you would tone because
you weren't working mothers we weren't
there and enough but also we get to do
the things we really didn't do which is
just you know get on the floor and play
with them if you're I don't know about
you but when I was a young mom when my
daughter was young I'd play with her but
I was also reading my research papers
over here and playing with her
grandmother's and grandfathers undivided
attention no I was told I was told back
in the day when they did a story about
crackberries both my kids said you
better pay attention to that because I'm
thinking no I'm definitely not a
crackberry person but there you go this
message will call you out oh you also
say let's see it's a great icebreaker
you do some of the biggest most
important interviews but talking about
being a
and parent is a huge ice breaker flow it
is it is first of all you and I just had
a chat before we went on uh-huh and I
said you have grandchildren and you said
no no nice and then you said I want to
be a grandmother oh I said my deepest
desire anyway there we were we were in a
conversation no people I'm not going to
ask either of you but it either you have
a grandchild you want to talk about it
you want to be a grandmother they want
to talk about it it's an interesting
question for me grandmother is how much
pressure you put on your kids if you
desperately want them yeah but they
don't listen to you it doesn't do any
good it just makes you feel a little
better but they don't listen to us one
of the interesting things you discovered
in this book to is the studies about the
importance of having a grandmother in
your life not just an American
agriculture but but across the across
the world but there have been very few
studies surprisingly about
grandparenting and all of that but there
have been some that say that children
who have grandparents and their lives
are more confident they don't they're
not as troublesome in school they do
better in school it's a relationship
that gives them a sense of family and
history and kids can confide more easily
and their grandparents for some reason
my grandmother was most important person
in my life beyond my parents say
thankful yes hmm this is not uncommon
and how many grandparents are raising
their grandchildren you'd be surprised
its enormous and if they're not doing it
full time they're they're in there is
what I call him granny nanny's
graininess no we recently started to see
pictures of President Trump walking with
his grass yeah you think that shows a
different side to him for a lot of
people I think so as they're getting on
marine one or Air Force One I was so
surprised to be honest that he didn't do
that during the campaign it would have
softened him I thought Hillary should
have even done more than she did people
have such positive feelings about
grandmothers particularly if you ask in
polls for example or focus groups what
do you think of grandmothers all he's
just divine wonderful warm
the words come tumbling out about
unconditional love and cookies and
warmth and acceptance so the image the
image of grandma has changed too because
it used to be grandma just sat in a
rocking chair and wat rocked and knitted
knitted clothes but they are really
there they're very hot dare I say
they're also very active it's a whole
different world I think for grandmother
some of them a baby boomer it's game
even baby boomers and their baby boomers
just want to be young and feel healthy
and energetic and guess what guess what
the average age of the first of a first
grandmother is the United States what
you want to try it's somewhere in the
50s 50 50 and for a man it's for
grandfather 54 that's young that's right
really young yeah so you're welcome
thank you it's all changed becoming
grandma is out in paperback tomorrow